- [Instructor] Two baseball teams
are comparing the number of fans
who attended their most recent games.
The attendance at the
Stanleyville Sliders' game
was 12,896 fans.
The attendance at the Benson Bats' game
was 12,901 fans.
Which team had more fans at their game?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
Alright, let's work
through this together now.
Stanleyville Sliders.
They tell us Stanleyville
Sliders' game was 12,000,
12,896
and there's a reason why
I'm writing it really large
right over there.
And then we see at the
Benson Bats' game was 12,901.
12,901.
So, the way I like to compare numbers
is I go to the largest place value first
and I compare.
Well, let's see.
They both have one 10,000.
So, they have the same number of 10,000s,
they have the same number of 1,000s,
but then when we get to 100s,
notice, Benson Bats has more 100s
than Stanleyville Sliders.
It doesn't matter what happens
in the 10s and ones place.
If they have more 100s over here.
So, Benson Bats this is a larger number.
So, which one has more fans at their game?
Benson's Bats,
and once again, I started
at the largest place value,
I start at the 10,000's place.
It was the same.
Then I move onto the next place.
It's the same.
Then I move onto the next place
but now in the 100's place
Benson's Bats is larger.
So, I know that Benson's Bats
has more fans than Stanleyville Sliders.
I could write this as 12,901
is greater than,
and I always remember the sign
by saying hey, it opens
to the larger value,
so this is gonna be greater than 12,896.
And you can even just think about it.
Just keep counting.
12,896, 12,897,
12,898,
12,899,
12,900
and then 12,901.
Alright, let's do another example.
The table shows the weights
of several animals at the zoo.
Put the animals in order
from lightest to heaviest.
The lightest animal should
be on the top of the list.
And so, you can see it right over here,
they gave us these three animals,
and if you're doing this on Khan Academy
you'd be able to click on
these and move them around
but I just copy and
pasted the actual image.
So, let's just think about these wights.
So, let's do the same thing.
Let's first look and
actually pause the video
and try to solve it on your own.
Alright, so if we first
look at the 1,000's place.
Remember, we start at
the largest place value,
so the 1,000's place,
they all have exactly two 1,000s,
so now we move on to the 100's place.
So, what the polar bear and crocodile
has two 100s but the
giraffe only has one 100,
so the giraffe is the lightest.
And remember, we're ordering
from lightest to heaviest
because this has the
least number of hundreds.
They all have the same
number of thousands,
and so then we move one space to the right
to the 100s and the giraffe
has the least number of 100s.
So, the giraffe is going
to be the lightest.
And so, let's think about
between the polar bear
and the crocodile.
They both have the same number of 1,000s,
they have the same numbers of 100s,
they have the same number of 10s
but notice, the polar has
more ones than the crocodile.
And so, the polar bear is heavier,
so the crocodile comes next,
it's the next heaviest
or the next lightest,
crocodile
and then the heaviest is the polar bear.
The polar bear.
Now once again,
you start at the largest
place value, you compare.
They were the same.
Then you go to the next largest.
Oh, there's a difference,
so this one must be lighter.
Doesn't matter what
happens in the 10s and ones
because it has fewer 100s
than these right over here.
And so, if you were sorting these around
you would want to put the giraffe first
and then you would put the crocodile,
and then the polar bear would stay last,
so actually you would just swap,
you would just swap these
two right over here.
Let's do one more.
This is a lot of fun.
Alright.
Let me scroll down a little bit.
Pause this video now
and see if you can solve this.
The table shows the elevations
for three mountains in North America.
Abby is trying to guess the elevation
of University Peak.
She knows that it is
taller than Mount Massive
but not as tall as Mount Alverstone.
So, it is between Mount
Alverstone and Mount Massive.
So, it is right over here.
Taller than Mount Massive
but not as tall as Mount Alverstone.
Alright.
Fill in the blank with an elevation
Abby could guess for the elevation
of University Peak.
Enter a whole number solution.
So, we just have to think of a number
that is larger than 14,428
and smaller than 14,400.
Well, one possibility
is we'll just add one
to Mount Massive.
So, one possibility is 14,429.
That would be taller than Mount Massive
but not as tall as Mount Alverstone.
Even though it has more
ones than Mount Massive,
everything else is the same,
it has fewer 100s than Mount Alverstone.
So, that could be.
We could write 14,429.
We could have also written 14,430
and we could have kept going
all the way until 14,499.
They want us to enter a
whole number solution.
So, any of these would have
been acceptable answers.